[Música]
el 15 de agosto del año 2021 los
talibanes se hicieron nuevamente con el
control del país luego de tomarse por
las armas kabul la capital del país esto
después de la huida del entonces
presidente ayer afgani y tras el anuncio
de eeuu de la retirada de sus tropas en
la actualidad las mujeres y gran parte
de la población viven con miedo con el
régimen reprimiendo sus derechos que
habían estado retomando en los años de
la democracia saludamos entonces a
nuestro primer mitad del día eres erick
fajardo profesor e investigador
universitario experto en temas de medio
oriente eri qué buena mañana del lunes
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de francia 24 para
analizar entonces un año de los
talibanes en el poder y le pregunto cómo
está la situación actual de afganistán
con los talibanes al mando de la nación
que tanto se han deteriorado además los
derechos de las mujeres los niños en el
país y los derechos humano en general
qué tal raúl sí creo que podemos centrar
la evaluación en un término que defina
lo que vive hoy día afganistán y es
inviabiliza ción el panorama general es
que más de 24 millones de habitantes
están consignados bajo un régimen
monotemático mono religioso y además
extremista fundamentalista esto ha
implicado un impacto fuertísimo en
varios ámbitos de lo que durante 20 años
de una democracia naciente se había
construido en términos de la sociedad
civil han colapsado las profesiones
liberales el ejercicio de derechos que
se había ampliado a las mujeres
irrestrictamente ha colapsado también la
manera en la que un país había aprendido
a vivir una generación o dos de afganos
y sobre todo la transnacionalidad del
trans nacionalismo el primer y el
segundo oleaje de inmigrantes refugiados
afganos que se fue a los estados unidos
vivió no más de 10 años allá y
regresaron con sus familias muchos de
quienes hoy día todavía viven en la peni
sanz son híbridos americanos afganos y
hay una fuerte cultura liberal todavía
persistente pese a las fuertes
restricciones hay movilizaciones de
sectores estratégicos como los
educadores las mujeres y protestas
porque esto ha implicado a afectar
profesiones que son parte de la
concepción en la sociedad democrática
como por ejemplo la prensa libre más del
40% de los medios se han cerrado en el
último año en conclusión si tuviéramos
que poner en la foto te diría raúl que
esto se parece mucho a lo que
seguramente fue hong kong un año después
de que gran bretaña salió y retornó a
dominio del partido comunista chino
y digamos que esto tenía fecha es decir
la llegada de los talibanes nuevamente
al poder porque se pudiera decir que
después del anuncio y la paulatina
retirada de las tropas estadounidenses y
la coalición internacional fue cuando
los talibanes digamos de alguna manera
tomaron fuerza para llegar hasta kabul
la capital también no tras la huida del
entonces presidente hace ráfaga ni
digamos que esto fue el detonante para
que los talibanes nuevamente se tomaran
con el control del país o sea era
digamos una crónica de una muerte
anunciada como se dice
los seguidores jamás se fueron esa es
una realidad que hay que afrontarla
seguramente kabul y las zonas
militarizadas urbanas de afganistán
estuvieron por 20 años bajo el control
del gobierno afgano de los gobiernos
afganos y de la protección de los
estados unidos y los aliados de la otan
en los hechos la administra rural
siempre tuvo una fuerte presencia aunque
clandestina del talibán que además
aceptas ella va desde un área que es
difícilmente definible en términos de
una frontera geográfica la cadena
montañosa gana la conexión con pakistán
y el mundo persa hacían demasiado
difícil pensar que de repente el talibán
podría haber sido extirpado
definitivamente nunca terminamos de
salir lo que yo creo que sería mejor
usar como un término para definir lo que
sucedió no es el comienzo de la guerra
sino el fin de la elipsis los 20 años de
democracia mal que bien generados por la
presencia de la otan y los estados
unidos fueron una elipsis en un
continuum que yo entiendo ha sido
siempre el de esta élite clasista pseudo
intelectual que se ha declarado la
tutelar de el resto de las etnicidades
hay al menos 2010 etnicidades seis
lenguas madre en un mismo territorio un
fuerte multiculturalismo que han sido
sofocados y que hoy día está viendo paso
a paso restringidas todas las conquistas
en términos de democracia querían
conseguir en 20 años ahora er y que
vamos un poco hacia atrás o no hablemos
de estos acuerdos de paz que se hicieron
en doha entre el gobierno del entonces
presidente ayer rafael y también los
talibanes no porque digamos que este
acuerdo nunca se concretó nunca se lleva
a la práctica pues lo vemos o no en
evidencia cuando los talibanes
finalmente se tomaron ya kabul hace un
año qué pasó con estos acuerdos la
verdad siempre tuvieron destinados al
fracaso
los acuerdos fueron siempre una posición
retórica de la opinión pública de un
talibán que necesitaba reinventarse y
proyectar la imagen que tan largamente
sus voceros trataron de proyectar de un
reformismo moderado esta inversión
atenuada que ellos vendieron tenía como
pieza clave de su histrionismo por
supuesto o no pero oslo y las otras
reuniones fueron va nada más eso fueron
posiciones de opinión pública de una
organización que entendía que las
condiciones objetivas para recuperar el
territorio órgano se estaban dando
conforme la política exterior de
washington cambiaba y más allá de que no
hubo una declarada
transformación en su ya vemos decir
doctrina de seguridad internacional él
era claro que los estados unidos
intentaba abandonar afganistán ahora en
qué medida eso colaboró la debilidad
enorme e higiénica de la democracia
afgana en qué medida a una cultura de
corrupción largamente engendrada desde
la época de la unión soviética o fue
copartícipe es difícil determinarlo lo
cierto es que en él binario de la
mayoría de las felicidades en afganistán
todavía existe una prevalencia una
especie de un yo diría gravitación de la
minoría de ascendencia persa islámica
sobre todas las otras posibles
etnicidad es que todavía existen en
afganistán